liebe georgio kann es sein dass ich dich
gestern in bonn auf der museumsmeile
gesehen habe aber irgendwie was du dann
so schnell weg liebe grüße
hallo wenn ja das kann sein
ich war tatsächlich dort mit ein paar
freunden ein netter ausflug war das
zumindest am anfang bis alles doof
beendet ist
ich habe auch nach dir geschaut aber die
ich nirgendwo gefunden wie immer scheint
es nicht zu klappen
guten morgen du bist du denn schon wach
weil ich nicht so viel getrunken habe
wie alle anderen gut dass wir beide
früher nach hause gegangen sind
die anderen haben bestimmt durch gemacht
oder nein die sind irgendwann 1 1 war
nach hause gekommen
was waren die laut dafür sind die beiden
jetzt bestimmt total verkatert im
gegensatz zu uns weist du die sind schon
wach ich weiß nicht aber ich glaube
nicht dass sie vor dem mittagessen
aufstehen
aber ich verspreche dir ich werde
langsam mal fragen was mit ihm los war
komisch oder alle männer sind komisch
wenn hat mir gerade dass er mich in bonn
gesehen hat aber ich frage mich warum
ich nicht angesprochen hat irgendwas ist
da komisch aber selbst wenn du den
ganzen abend neben einem mann sitzt
heißt das noch lange nicht dass er dich
auch anspricht
ja da ist reza wirklich eine harte nuss
mein handy piept kann sein dass du
gleich weg bist mein akku ist leer
dann hat das handy doch auf ihr aber das
ladegerät ist in der küche
hallo